smiley coming off a start on april the
11th against the phillies it's been a
while for drew hopefully he has his a
plus stuff
in game two pavon smith the center
fielder will get us started
but uh congratulations to pat
haven smith looking to get him started
on the right note and there it goes
pavon smith diamondback strike first
he tripled in game what he homers to
start game two
lift on left get it right now so much
for that
[Applause]
that's a fair ball down the line
it's by reilly at third carson's in at
third base and cabrera has himself
a stand-up double good start for the
diamondbacks
they play straight up for matheson the
one-two
he swings and wraps it diving stopped by
swanson his only play will be the first
in time to get mavis in
scoring is kelly and it's two-nothing
d-backs e-backs
have a matter third now with two outs
two-nothing they lead and here's peralta
one-two pitch peralta gets it up in the
air
deep right field there it goes
diamondbacks in atlanta two home runs in
the first against drew smiley and it's
four nothing left on left
two lefties in the inning both take
smiley deep how about that he's got i'm
in at second two outs now for josh rojas
here's the one oh to rojas he swings and
launches one to right ocuna racing over
can't get it one hop against the fence
ahmed scores rojas digging for two the
throw not in time
he's in with a head first slide rbi
double josh rojas
five-nothing d-backs in the first it's
madison bumgarner
who got his first win last sunday five
very solid innings in washington
popped up to cut fastball nick ahmed
mad bum goes to the curve ball and gets
his first strikeout
that gets a desired result gets freddie
freeman to swing
through an off-speed pitch up and out
over the plate that doesn't happen often
on the ground to third another spin and
throw by his dribble and there's your
shot
down one two three first for madison
bumgarner
who has a five nothing lead
and that's over the outside corner and
smith will
be rung up for the first strikeout for
drew smiley one away
swing and a miss and smiley rebounds
with a one two three second with a
couple of punch outs
you can spot that fastball and throw a
good curveball he should be just fine
with a five-nothing lead
one more time 4-1 and they roll it
kind of death we'll talk more about that
as we go on but it really can
run on guys pitch bounced to short
charging ahmed he throws that one over
the top low
and scooped on the backhand by matheson
five-nothing d-backs top of the third
eduardo escobar leads off
as escobar launches the 1-1 down the
line and left towards the corner
it is gone home run eduardo escobar
well he went down and got this ball and
you've been saying all along how
what a good low ball hitter he is and
i think he might have been a little out
front of this and hooked it and
just weren't sure if it was going to
stay fair curveball
and sure enough it's hooking and it hits
the foul pool
pole you know straight down so i didn't
get to the struggles thankfully
uh you know for the most part
well he's got that curveball working it
wasn't quite down like carson kelly
wanted at webby but here's a curveball
to riley
yeah i think it's a pitch that he's
using well today that one kind of did
spin out and hang up out over
gets the swing in the drive to deep left
field peralta going back he's near the
fence and he's got it
about a step shy of the fence and
thunderous applause from stephen
crichton and kevin ginkel for the catch
by peralta two outs
for them to pick that up and see what's
coming
and smiley waves at a curveball looks
like another big step forward so far
today
right by freddie freeman that strikeout
number four for manbon
who has now set down seventh street
called strike three madison bumgarner
five strikeouts
four no hittings he's retired eight
straight
falls into strike one on one out check
swing roller
tomlins got it he'll take it to the bag
himself nice play
six runs in four innings and riley says
he's got
room down the third base line puts the
squeeze on that
t-backs in atlanta going not only for
the double-header sweep
but the double-header complete game
shutout madison bumgarner has blanked
atlanta so far through four
albies pops it up shallow left center
pavement smith is underneath it
and that's nine straight set down by
macbook darno hit into a double play his
first trip
six-nothing d-backs bottom five the 1-0
swinging a fly ball to center field
smith going back
now a step onto the warning track makes
the catch
two outs
out to center pavon smith is there
madison bumgarner has faced the minimum
through five
josh has got a base hit here comes ahmed
make it seven nothing diamondbacks
another rbi for josh rohan
[Applause]
[Music]
that looked a lot more like the
controlled swing we saw from josh
madison bumgarner has faced the minimum
through five he's out there with a seven
nothing lead to start the sixth
one and two on riley now and there's
strike three six strikeouts for mad mom
who has now set down 12 in a row since
the ahmed era
here's the o2 grounder to the left side
charging ahmed has it throws on the run
in time to get him
bumgarner's pace face the minimum
through six
we will also say that no pitcher has
ever
in one of these seven inning game double
headers thrown a seven inning game
without any hits no one's ever done that
yet
i got him seven strikeouts and 15
in a row set down by madboom
in the air along the left field line
ahmed and peralta nick and foul ground
that he's got it
right field rojas is there madison
bumgarner
a complete game shutout no hits for the
braves in
seven and the diamondbacks sweep the
double header they win game two seven
nothing
look at that right there that says it
all